[Music]
when scientists began observing microbes
many of the tools that we rely on today
of course had not yet been invented
now microscopes existed but they were
generally simpler tools and they also of
course lacked cameras that could take a
snapshot of the organisms and objects
being so closely watched still the
scientists were exploring the uncharted
territory of the micro cosmos and words
alone would not suffice to describe the
strange beings they uncovered so early
microscopic research was not just a
scientific endeavor it was an artistic
one relying on illustrations of diatoms
and rotifers and other creatures that
could then be disseminated to those who
were curious to see these new wonders
one of the most impressive collections
of microbial illustrations was drawn by
Christian Gottfried Ehrenberg a German
naturalist in the 19th century who
amassed thousands and thousands of
geological and biological samples and
who in turn produced thousands of
sketches based on the observations he
made under the microscope today we will
be taking a bit of a turn from our
normal content shifting our focus from
microbes to a scientist whose extensive
documentation of them influenced the
fields of microbiology and micro
paleontology we're going to be talking
about ehrenburg's life while showing you
his drawings which come from the
collection of his works maintained at
the Museum of Natural History in Berlin
and we will also share our own videos of
those same species so you can see how
the details he sketched out by hand
stack up against what our cameras can
record from our microscopes today so
let's start with the early days of
Kristian Gottfried ehrenburg's
scientific career
born in 1795 Ehrenburg earned his
doctorate in 1818 from the university of
berlin in his thesis he described 250
species of fungi from around the city
but most notable was his observation
that fungi are born from spores and not
as many theorized at the time
spontaneously generated two years later
Arenberg joined an archeological
expedition to Egypt that would end up
somewhat disastrous at one point the
funders claimed to have quote lost the
money meant for the travellers then one
of ehrenburg's compete reott almost died
from a snakebite and then later actually
died of typhus despite the physical and
emotional trials Arenberg was able to
send tens of thousands of animal plant
and rock samples to Germany except that
when he returned home five years later
many of those samples had been damaged
and another bunch had been sold this was
a discouraging outcome but when
Ehrenburg was offered the chance to join
the esteemed naturalist alexander
humboldt on an expedition to russia in
siberia in 1829 he seized the
opportunity fortunately this expedition
turned out to be much less calamitous
both of these expeditions provided
Arenberg with a wealth of samples to
draw from in his study of the natural
world and more importantly they would
shape his fascinations with microbes
which he called infusoria Arenberg was
loyal to his microscope relying on the
same one for decades to study the
infusoria sampled from various waters he
uncovered some of the ways these
little-known creatures were connected
with the larger world they lived in like
the planktonic microorganisms he
realized were the source of
phosphorescence in the Red Sea and the
diatoms whose silica casings
became part of the earth now many of the
samples he observed under the microscope
were embedded into mica and covered in
Canada balsam magnifying his various
specimens 300 times Ehrenburg drew out
what he saw with a fine gray pencil
sometimes adding pigment using
watercolor but no man can be correct all
the time and ehrenburg's refusal to
update his microscope may have led to
one of his most notable mistakes he
thought that all of the organisms he
observed must be animals even the
unicellular was in some cases what he
claimed were eggs sexual organs were
later revealed to be nuclei still
mistakes aside his work further
solidified the study of infusoria and
his collections and remarks on microbial
fossils paved the way for micro
paleontology while ehrenburg's later
expeditions were not quite as distant as
his first two this was an age where
natural ists were venturing all over the
globe to gather samples and Arenberg
happened to be corresponding with quite
a few of those natural ists
they would send him bits of living
things rock soil and more from just
about everywhere it's like a postcard
for your naturalist pen pal
Charles Darwin even sent him dust that
had blown onto his ship near the Cape
Verde Islands in 1854 Arenberg published
one of his most famous works micro
geology I don't speak German so I could
just say micro geology it's a two-volume
text that compiled observations on North
American and European sediments and the
microbes they housed the book would cost
you $72 which was not cheap in 1854 but
it might be worth it for 4,000 of these
illustrations
Arenberg died in 1867 after which his
collection was eventually moved to the
Museum of Natural History in Berlin part
of the collections value lies in just
how vast it is both in the types of
samples it contains and geographical
range they come from in total there are
more than 40,000 microscope sample
preparations thousands of specimens and
illustrations and hundreds of letters
his daughter Clara helped with both the
drawings and compiling an index to link
all these samples together which has
proven essential and making sense of his
immense work but the knowledge contained
in this collection would become hard to
reach for some time for decades a mix of
war politics and finances kept it
inaccessible it was even at one point
believed to be lost fortunately that was
not true and in the late 1960s curators
began to restore it progress was slow
and briefly threatened when in 1982 a
fire broke out in the museum's roof
close to where the collection was stored
the museum curators responded quickly to
save it and ultimately these historical
documents survived with only little
water damage and through all of these
dire situations the curators persevered
in their intention to make the
collection accessible in 1998 they
released a cd-rom containing scanned
images of the illustrations letters and
indices and now if you want to explore
the images at your leisure the museum
has made them available to download on
their website and why wouldn't you so
there's a link of the description the
more recent availability of the
collection has inspired more scientific
work a group of Brazilian scientists
studied ehrenburg's records on diatoms
samples taken from their country
essentially repatriating data and
allowing for a study of biodiversity
last time another group of researchers
extracted and examined bacteria from
some of Darwin's dust samples confirming
just how resilient bacteria can be
technology of course has given us new
ways to document and share the microbial
world one of the coolest parts of our
job as we assemble each episode of
journey to the macrocosmos is that we
get to spend so much time watching
microbes and appreciating their beauty a
pursuit that ehrenberg could surely
relate to but the fact that we can
record what we see on video is built on
advances in microscopes and cameras
moreover when we want to share what we
see with the world we don't have to send
you images via mail or compile them over
two decades we just hit a button on
YouTube and the whole world can watch if
it chooses that same technological
progress has made ehrenburg's collection
more accessible in an age of big data
his illustrations and his documents are
a physical trove of information whose
promise we're still understanding it's a
common mistake to think of science and
art as separate endeavors but they are
linked by creativity and by the human
desire to make sense of the world around
us time and invention have only given us
more ways to engage science and art
together and in the same way that we've
found beauty and meaning in the stars
above us there are also answers in the
infusoria that surrounds
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us thank you to all of
the curators who protected ehrenburg's
work and also a thanks to Arenberg
himself and know he's not around to hear
it but his work is appreciated and of
course thank you to all of the people
whose names are on the screen right now
if you like this show they are the
reason it can exist they are our
supporters on patreon if you would like
to join them check out
patreon.com/lenguin
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James you can check out
Jam and germs on Instagram and if you
want to see more from us every week just
go to youtube.com slash micro cosmos to
see what we've been up to